Fox threatens to sue Tucker Carlson for
violating his contract with the launch
of his new Twitter show that 80 million
people and Counting watched so why are
they doing this
I think they want Tucker Carlson to shut
up until after the election it makes no
sense why they would take him off the
air but then also say you can't talk
like he made a Twitter video and they're
saying you've breached your contract why
yeah because he posted a video of
himself on Twitter that's normal social
media this is what we're just talking
about with critical thinking in the
press the Press does not want anyone
breaking the narrative so they remove
Tucker from the airwaves exactly and so
we saw this with James O'Keefe right and
project Veritas coming after him
again not knowing a whole lot about the
law or the legal precedent that's there
the fact that they would remove him from
their organization and then try to stop
him from doing his journalist at work
when he's no longer with that
organization suggests to me in my
personal humble opinion that their
issues with the journalism he's doing
because he's no longer affecting them in
any way unless that's the thing that
concerns them so similarly with Tucker
Carlson being Alison from Fox a lot of
people were making the argument that
they were only throwing him out into the
cold because of this Dominion settlement
even though Tucker didn't really say
anything about dominion and
now you have them trying to silence him
even though they don't have any more
liability there so it makes it perfectly
clear that the purpose of casting him
out wasn't like to settle a lawsuit it
was because they really didn't like what
he was saying and they're upset that
he's saying it's somewhere else now yeah
I think it was both though I mean look
they they paid out almost a little over
three quarters of a billion dollars
right so they're they're super sensitive
to be in suit again at the same time one
of the things I learned you know having
worked in media as long as I did it
there was a tremendous amount of
pettiness in the c-suite especially when
the hosts or or particular hosts like
Tucker become wealthy and powerful and
beyond the reach of of that c-suite of
management they become that it's not
that they're seen as uncontrollable
because you got to extend you know your
key employees a certain amount of trust
right you gotta let them be who they are
and they're adults and they're
responsible and Tucker never crossed
lines right even Sensational but that's
what made him good
but they get jealous it's weird they get
really jealous when the talent becomes
more famous more powerful than them and
I think this became an ego battle so
they they say it's about uh the Dominion
lawsuit and they force them out and he
goes off on his own and they think haha
we've got him he's gonna go bro he's a
wealthy guy he's generally wealthy now
he's fine but he goes out there he goes
on Twitter and then they start doing the
math and they realize wait a second if
this guy takes even a third of his
audience with him and he charges them a
couple of bucks a month a few bucks a
month he's gonna be doubling what we
paid him while he really doesn't need us
he's not going to come back and grovel
so now it just seems to me to be real
Petty nonsense like they're just gonna
try to make his life possible he doesn't
need them I wonder how much of this is
we must silence certain voices sure
before 2024 or Trump wins so James
O'Keefe Veritas not only freezes him
they then sue him yup Fox News does the
exact same thing
now look maybe it's coincidental that
almost at the exact same time Veritas
suspends O'Keefe but locks him in the
company Fox suspends Tucker but keeps
him in the company and then both get
sued for trying to do their work to
continue their work it seems a little
bit odd just saying I think I think the
O'Keefe situation was different though
and I had some unique insight to this
because I'm friendly with two different
board members who are on opposite sides
of the issue and well you know the old
saying right there's two sides of the
story and the truth is somewhere in the
middle but the one thing both of them
uh agreed upon when they told me their
versions and I wasn't with them was that
O'Keefe was never fired
that he was benched and that the that he
did violate the NDA and that's what they
went after him for and this was right so
they tell James he can't work and then
when he says I'm going to do my own
thing they say we're suing you know to
stop you from doing that well so that's
evil I'm with you on that but what they
had said both of them said well it was
more about the violation of the NDA and
going out there now it's his NDA well
it's but there's still a 501. yeah I
don't care no no I hear you I'm the
lawyers are weird people right lawyers
lawyers look at things differently any
anybody at Veritas who is in agreement
with what they're doing to James is an
evil despicable piece of garbage but Tim
I'm not arguing with you lawyers are
lawyers you know lawyers the board hired
lawyers to do this for them sure James
starts project Veritas he runs it and
everyone's behind him then they come and
subvert him benching him whatever you
want to call it shutting down his
ability to do his job so what does he do
I'll start another company now they're
suing him yo that that the only
intention perceivably is to stop James
O'Keefe from doing his work look I'll
play it and look at what they're doing
right now with Tucker there's literally
no reason to take his show off the air
and then tell him he can't post Twitter
videos I agree with you what I'm saying
is because having been through dumb
lawsuits on both sides as plaintiff and
defendant in business once you involve
attorneys things snowball out of control
so
you can't deny that Veritas is
inextricably linked to O'Keefe right
it's his brand he's the brand they're
they're one and the same the minute
lawyers got involved this thing was
going sideways same with Tucker because
in the exact same way well because look
they want to build and they've got they
know both organizations have Deep
Pockets for what reason would you
suspend someone and prohibit them from
doing work
non-competes are enforced every day I
don't I don't tend to agree with them
how enforceable they are as a matter of
law but that's just what lawyers do
because they want to rack up as much
billable as many billable hours as they
can look I picked the whole you can't
you can't pass this off on lawyers I
reject that but how if you're the board
of a 501 and your Law Firm turns around
and says project Veritas could have said
let's just let James do his thing well
here's what I'm going to agree with you
on that I think the entire thing was the
most ham-fisted moronic PR exercise I've
ever seen and Fox News all the same if
they don't want Tucker around they just
say go do your thing well they should
told Tucker to go do his thing because
Tucker's got a a different situation
there because he really number one
different rules apply right one of the
things to Veritas whether it's valid or
not is that there was uh finances were
mishandled now I've spoken to some of
their very big donors and those big
donors said we don't care if O'Keefe
flew on a solid gold Gulfstream six we
didn't donate X dollars to nickel and
dime him we donated for results he got
us results we don't care how he spent
the money if we gave him five million
dollars and he spent all but a penny so
herself and got the job done we're happy
so James made the mistake of bringing on
corrupt envious scumbags to his board
who have destroyed project Veritas look
I think I think the brand right he the
brand is him but I think when you and
now they're trying to stop him from even
doing more work these are evil people
lesson is this I mean you know this you
run a successful business right I've got
Partners where a small fun but we do
pretty well never bring adversary is on
to a board of directors it's the dumbest
thing people do also especially when you
want to be a proprietary entity don't
there's this weird sense of nobility
where people and look I'm gonna say it
here right now I I don't make any
apologies for having moved on from Trump
to DeSantis Trump's Personnel picks bear
this out if Trump had had better
Personnel Acumen he'd be a very
successful second term president this
happens everywhere so it's not unique to
uh Veritas Fox is a different animal
because Tucker didn't pick the board but
James should have picked more wisely but
then again he's a personality he's not a
business guy yeah he should not have
started a non-profit yeah well that too
because it was he explained this how it
started was that he wanted to do some
work he needed to raise money he wasn't
thinking of it as a commercial Venture
so he said how do I raise money well if
you got to be a 501c3 so okay so I'll
file for that he was a young guy sure
for me I've had other llc's and other s
Corps and whatever so I I'm like this is
the structure that we use and there are
even arguments to be made for C corpse
over s Corps for a variety of reasons
that's right but going the nonprofit
route put them in a particularly
vulnerable vulnerable position for the
thing that he built and then these evil
people these these brain slug people
come in and destroyed project Veritas
for for what purpose other than because
they're envious and evil people end of
story James O'Keefe founded it he's the
leader of it he's the one in charge and
if the donors are happy and the work was
getting done the only reason to
interfere was because they were jealous
evil or trying to destroy Veritas
intentionally I don't think they were
trying to destroy it but I do think they
but they had no reason to destroy it
because the money was coming in and the
expose were strong I just think then why
file a lawsuit because I think people
people have power trips and and they
have power trips through tunnel vision
and they're and they're they become
Crusaders and they don't realize the
collateral damage that's occurring when
they become Crusaders I I don't think it
was a I I don't think it was a proactive
you know a career assassination of him
it turned into that I just think a bunch
of people said well we've got to do this
we're the board of directors we're the
austere board and we don't care who the
personality is and in the real world
that's just baronic that's not the way
things work and it's snowballed out of
control and but look it bit them in the
butt at the end of the day the
organization's never going to be the
same I get the emails I don't look at
them the same way I'm with you I don't
know that I'm the same way anymore yeah
it does but but it's not just that uh so
is the argument that these are the
stupidest people on the planet because I
don't buy it filing a lawsuit against
James O'Keefe was basically publicly
declaring you are shutting Veritas down
yeah but the the play Devil's Advocate
on that if in the Bible I didn't see him
but the way it was explained to me
in a 501 if you don't follow the rules
you could be prosecuted criminally and
so if lawyers step in if you're a board
member and you're one of the board
members that was Pro O'Keefe now you've
got a law firm sitting in front of you
in a good boy and saying look guys we
wouldn't have advised you to go down
this road but you did
and if you don't do a b and c now
and there is something well but
but here's my point once an attorney
tells you that and says to you you might
be personally liable if you don't do
these things that we're recommending how
many people are going to go out there
and say okay I'll take the personal
liability because the the actual real
alternative is to say make it above
board which would mean they go to James
O'Keefe and say I agree normal formal
termination and we're clean have a nice
day when James O'Keefe came out and said
he was terminated all I have to do is
say agreed or the idea that they're like
oh no we're gonna be prosecuted because
James is violating his NBA back up go
one I agree with you 100 here what they
should have done was call the attorneys
in before they ever took action yeah
Sato Keith at a table in a closed door
room like this and said hey guys to the
attorneys hypothetically if this were
the situation with an executive here and
we wanted to maintain the status quo and
still be compliant how could we go about
that and everybody could have shook
hands and walked out of that room
as friends yeah that's where they that's
where they screwed it that's what makes
me think it was an emotional response
that they just did it to him in public I
think it was the way it was done evil I
disagreed with greedy I played Devil's
Advocate because I've sat on boards but
the way it was done in terms of a PR
exercise was devastating the
organization unless it was on purpose
yeah I don't think it was like I said
I've spoken to both sides even the Provo
key faction
on the board didn't feel it was done on
purpose they felt like you that it was a
moronically horrible execution but they
didn't feel it was malice in it how is
there anything other than a proki
faction to what he started people get
very intense people get nervous if they
think they're going to be personally
sued or potentially could be prosecuted
they tend to change their perspective
you resign it doesn't matter you already
knew about it the minute the minute you
became aware of the situation your
resignation that's an insulator that's
the problem thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time